utilisé une fausse qualité pour entrer
chez vous et dérober vos biens c'est le
délit de vol par ruse commis par
certains délinquants
une conférence organisée ce jeudi 15
décembre par la police nationale de
verseilles visait à se prévenir de ces
situations
c'est un phénomène assez compliqué assez
difficile à interrompre parce que il ne
se produit pas sur la voie publique se
produit si ce produit au domicile des
victimes
donc les patrouilles qui sont dans les
rues sont assez massive
la carte de police avaient très vite
d'anti fiable c'est une petite carte de
crédit alors qu'on sait que parfois les
voyous qu'ils écartent qui ne ressemble
à son ambassade et grande carte blanche
utilisation de l'antre bailleur composer
le 17 en cas de doute ce sont des
réflexes à adopter chaque année près de
15 vols par ruse sont répertoriés à
versailles les voyous agissant général
entre 11h et 14h chez les personnes les
plus vulnérables les personnes âgées
on est curieux de connaître qu'est ce
qu'il faut faire pour être ne pas être
concernés dans les arnaques
on vient
pour avoir d'autres d'autres
renseignements d'autres notre
d'indication sur toutes les façons dont
on peut être grande et quand on est âgé
et handicapé d'éviter certains pièges il
y en a que je connais mais y'en a que je
connais pas donc comment repérer les
arnaques
le centre communal d'action sociale de
versailles libre des plateaux repas chez
les 172 personnes vulnérables recensé un
moyen pour la commune de lutter contre
le risque de vol par ruse
à travers ce contact les services de la
ville sont informés d'éventuels risques
pour les personnes âgées de contact
anormaux et peuvent prévenir les
services de police avec lesquels il ya
une coordination constante l'article 311
tiré 4 du code pénal sanctionne de cinq
ans d'emprisonnement et de 75000 euros
damende ce type de délit